the five-week training program for
agricultural regions
one two and seven exposed farmers to
updated agricultural practices
which are likely to improve farming
processes
good agricultural practices cultivation
management and pesticide use
post-harvest technologies record keeping
and
marketing and business planning were
among other fundamental topics covered
permanent secretary of the department of
agriculture barrymore felicia
in encouraging farmers to network and
strengthen relationships among
themselves
says that the full benefits of this
recent farmer training program
can only be realized if knowledge
sharing remains at the forefront of
farmers agendas
according to him education and attitude
add two critical characteristics for
success
in the agricultural industry with
education
and attitude perhaps you can get to
good agricultural practices but if you
want to distinguish yourself
i say you have to get to great
agricultural practices
you have to put a capital gg on that
so you have to distinguish yourself and
take that and learn
you have to evolve as a farmer evolve as
a businessman evolve as a person
if you want to succeed and have a
premium product
in this market to distinguish yourself
and to add value to what you produce
ambassador of the taiwan embassy to
saint lucia his excellency peter
cheyenne chen
in extending his congratulatory message
to graduates
encouraged farmers to take advantage of
all the opportunities provided
by the seven crops project in order to
promote local production and
consumption the government of taiwan
has been working with the government of
sinusia
to promote several important crops on a
sustainable basis
since 2019.
every successful project comes down to
people
that's why this training program are one
of the most critical parts of the
southern cross project
to date over 250 farmers have been
certified through the enhancement
of the efficiency of production
distribution supply chains
in the fruits and vegetable sector
project from the communications unit of
the ministry of agriculture i am anesia
antoine reporting